as the effects of climate change become
increasingly pronounced across the
African continent more than a fifth of
its 1.3 billion people don't have enough
to eat with water shortages and extreme
weather events being the main
contributing factors Somalia though is
at the epicenter of this deepening
climate and hunger crisis that is
gripping most severely the East Africa
region Bloomberg traveled to galkayo in
central Somalia last month where the
impact of the worst drought to impact
the country in four decades was laid
bare vast tracks of Countryside were
transformed into Barren Wasteland crops
had been decimated and children were
dying of starvation one woman Nemo Hasa
had lost five of her ten children to
starvation and disease within the past
year after the drought wiped out most of
her family's goat herd its main source
of income official data shows that 900
other children under the age of five
have died across Somalia since January
the true tally is unknown and unlikely X
exponentially higher because vast areas
are under the control of al-shabab
insurgents and inaccessible to officials
and Aid workers in the area surrounding
more than half of the children are
already considered malnourished
Countrywide more than 350 000 Somalian
children have been treated for the
condition this year almost half of
somalia's 17 million people are in
urgent need of Aid and more than one
million have abandoned their homes in
search of food and grazing rains have
failed for five consecutive seasons and
water shortages are even worse than in
the early 1990s when a famine claimed
about 260 000 lives the UN expects a
famine to be declared soon in three
isolated regions of the country
foreign